all right welcome to the iphone 13
unboxing or wait hold that thought we
got an iphone 13 and the 13 mini and 13
pro
and the 13 pro max i'm sure the stuff
inside of the box is very similar but
let's get into it
so we're gonna unbox every phone in the
new lineup and i'm gonna start with the
standard iphone 13 in this new blue
color that i think is actually my
favorite of the new phones and it's this
thin box again as you can see because
there's no power brick included in the
box but as you may have noticed there's
also no plastic shrink wrap this year so
i guess it's time to give apple a little
bit of credit for their use of recycled
materials to offset their environmental
impact so recycled box cardboard
recycled aluminum recycled phone design
but here we can see the phone in all its
glory and i can just fire it up real
quick before looking at the accessories
but the rest of the stuff in the box is
pretty much the same you get a lightning
to usbc cable and you get some paperwork
a sim card tool
and an apple sticker that is not colored
just a white apple sticker
but yeah that's the iphone 13 in the
hand for the first time let's grab the
13 mini next so this is actually a new
darker color it's called midnight it's
not quite black but it is a very very
very dark blue but i think the camera
bump might actually also be
close to black on this midnight iphone
then the pro iphones here the pro
iphones come in black boxes again so
this is the gold 13 pro a lot of the
same stuff again white apple sticker
normal accessories and then the sierra
blue 13 pro max big phone big camera
bump which i'll get to in a second and
just have to make sure but yes they do
in fact all come with white apple
stickers but
that
is the unboxing and that is your iphone
13 lineup
so by the time you're watching this i
have been testing these new iphones for
the better part of five days now which
not quite enough time for a full review
but definitely enough for some solid
first impressions so that's what i'm
going to give you today also make sure
to subscribe to be among the first to
see the full reviews when they drop and
also let me know which one you want to
see reviewed first but yeah from the
outside it looks almost identical to
last year's phone and in the hand it
feels almost the same too although it is
a quarter of a millimeter thicker which
i don't notice at all but then also
about 20 grams heavier which i do notice
not by much but i did notice because i'm
so calibrated to the 12. now most of
this extra heft is from a slightly
larger battery capacity and the more i
use these phones this is starting to be
interesting the more i'm starting to
think that this may be the most
underrated new change on these iphones i
have been very impressed with the
battery here especially on the larger
phones so i had a day with the 13 pro
where i had nearly five hours of screen
on time with half battery left which is
crazy good and that's not even the pro
max so we'll see if this continues to
hold up but that's definitely something
to keep an eye on this year that i
wasn't expecting as much you know
obviously it's a pretty minor update but
in the grand scheme of things even if
apple didn't add crazy fast charging or
ultra fast wireless charging the fact
that they did make the phone a little
thicker and a little heavier for a
little bit of a bigger battery
all right yeah thumbs up but really the
only other two updates to evaluate are
the cameras and the screen so for these
cameras i already have a bunch of sample
photos here and i encourage you to
follow me on twitter or instagram
because i'm going to keep posting new
sample photos and videos as i keep
testing these but overall my impression
so far is still a great set of cameras
especially in broad daylight of course
and the bigger improvements will be seen
in more edge cases like low light fast
moving subjects etc definitely going to
shoot some more of that type of stuff
but the star of the show really is all
the sensors are bigger and better and
they're still 12 megapixels each but
that ultra wide in particular looks much
better with the sharpness across the
whole frame and i'm pumped that the new
telephoto on the pro is 3x slightly
better than the 2.5 x on the pro max
last year and again a larger sensor but
that's why all these cameras are so
massive on the back of the phones too
it's of course an aesthetic change
between this year's phone and last year
the cameras are also now diagonal on the
13 and 13 mini not just to look
different but to fit that new hardware
and it's just an overall bigger camera
bump that's super duper thick damn boy
i do already have a couple quirks things
that i've noticed about these cameras
though one
prores so these pro cameras the 13 pro
13 pro max we're supposed to have pro
res video super high quality kodak
that's used all the time in the video
world uh
it's not here it's not here yet anyway
this is a coming soon feature
that will apparently be pushed sometime
with a software update again i can't
evaluate it it's supposed to be here but
it's not and apple's usually pretty good
about eventually delivering things they
promise especially in software
but it's not here yet but then number
two the the new macro capability on the
iphone pros ultra wides so when you get
close enough to an object within about
14 centimeters or something the cameras
automatically switch to the ultra wide
and that's because it has the super
close up capability so you can keep
going in and get as close as two
centimeters from something and it'll
still be in focus which is great it's
better than some dinky two megapixel
macro camera it's super high quality
it's taking a crop from a higher quality
sensor instead it's been fun to play
with but
but
this all happens automatically with no
manual override at all
not a huge deal to some people but like
you can see the switch when it happens
in the viewfinder but there is no
indication that it has switched cameras
at all so you walk in closer to
something it switches to the crop of the
ultra wide but it still says 1x on the
right side like it's still coming from
the main camera when it isn't but now
all the natural bokeh from the primary
camera's focal length is gone and it
doesn't let me switch back that's the
thing i can hit the 1x all i want
nothing happens and that's the
difference between getting this
and moving one inch closer auto
switching and getting this
it just looks worse now maybe they do
that automatically to prevent some of
the fringing that can come with close-up
subjects from these larger primary
sensors
but on a pro phone
i would like at least to be able to hit
the 1x button and switch back to the
primary sensor just give me the the
button for the control small complaint
though but then also there is the new
cinematic mode which is on all the
phones and it is such a new it is a
software feature but it is so processor
intensive that it's only going to be on
iphone 13 and later it's not coming to
older iphones but this was described on
stage as a focus rocking and ai based
face tracking for shooting more
cinematic videos
i think this is going to look like
to regular people
like video portrait mode so first of all
in the camera modes it's got its own
dedicated swipe over panel so there's
portrait photos then regular photos then
regular videos
then cinematic mode which immediately
applies the fake extra depth of field
now there's way more manual control so
i'm thinking maybe i'll try to shoot a
whole video or something with this to
see if it's worth your time for people
trying to make videos on the iphone but
for now for normal people getting this
phone
yeah that background blur is gonna get
the most attention it's like video
portrait mode so i got a lot of camera
testing to do but you know it didn't
take me very long to evaluate is the new
screens so
they're all the same sizes last year but
they are brighter they've got a slightly
20
smaller notch thanks to the movement of
that earpiece up top and the pro
versions now have 120 hertz promotion so
the smaller notch it's all right i guess
to my eye honestly it makes almost no
difference because you don't actually
get much screen real estate back apple
didn't even have the courtesy to add an
option to see the battery percentage up
there in the status bar or do anything
with the extra screen real estate the
120 hertz promotion though it's legit
it's amazing it's very nice looking and
it's about damn time and i'm going to
probably say the same thing again when
it finally comes to the pixel 6 also
this year but yeah it's about time now
to be fair apple's had in my description
some of the smoothest feeling 60 hertz
phones of the past but the second i
unlocked the 13 pro for the first time
out the box and i could see that high
refresh rate i loved it i mean you can
see my actual real-time reaction in the
bts video that we just dropped on the
studio channel but it looks great super
smooth animations and pretty much every
single app and every single animation
even pre-launch of the phone is moving
at 120 hertz right off the bat even the
classics like instagram and tiktok that
still need to get updated to look
correct on this barely released phone
are 120 hertz
but yeah high refresh rate for the win
it won't translate here of course on
camera in this 30 fps video but yeah
you'll have to trust my words it's
really good even now better than the
ipad pro because it's oled now it's 120
hertz hdr oled it's beautiful aside from
that here's some a15 bionic geekbench
scores just to sort of round out the
initial impressions it's obviously a
very fast chip it is a little bit of a
bump over last year
there you go
that sort of rounds up my initial
thoughts on the iphone 13. a lot of
friends are asking should i update is it
worth it even though it's a small update
over the 12 maybe they have an older
phone should they get this phone first
of all friends
wait for the full review it's coming
very soon that'll have all the details
but yeah it is such a minor set of
changes that i think if you were
thinking about getting the 13
specifically
then you might consider a freshly
discounted 12
because the phone is so similar and it
just dropped out the 13 came out with
the mini the battery life on the smaller
one was bad so maybe you'll get the 13
mini instead with the better battery
life and with the pros of course there's
120 hertz to consider but overall for
people with older phones like iphone 10s
iphone 8s any older phone this
represents a solid now a good buy again
and hey if you do get the 13 you might
as well protect your investment i mean
that one terabyte iphone 13 pro max cost
1600 bucks
wouldn't want that to crack on the first
week would you shout out to the d-bear
and grip case no better way to protect
your investment i'll link that below but
let me know in the comments what stuff
do you want to see covered in detail in
the full review and also which one
should i review first i have a feeling
it'll probably be the 13 standard but
let me know anyway we'll check those out
either way that's been it thanks for
watching
catch you guys soon
peace